hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in chapter 8 of notes from underground
Fyodor Dostoevsky has this extended
passage where he's discussing the
relationship between reason and desire
and will and wish are also brought in
there as are the sort of utopian or
humanitarian and whatever we want to
call them plans of reformers people who
want to change society people who want
to gradually change or improve or unveil
genuine human nature as they take it and
I think this would apply to many moral
philosophers as well not just those
engaged in you might say political and
social projects but also those who are
focused on just one's own self
improvement and the basic idea that all
of these people have that he's attacking
is that in some way our desires and
desire in general could be made fully
rational that is the conflict that we
often experience between desire which
wants what it wants and and if we're not
paying attention will steer us into
whatever it is that it wants us to do
and it's also part of ourselves so it's
us
who are you know being steered that way
and then our Faculty of rationality that
tells us well this is a good thing for
you to do and this is a bad thing for
you to do and this this goes all the way
back to you know Plato and if you think
about his Republic and three parts of
the soul you know the desires at the
Fumiya and the another kind of desire
through most the desire for recognition
for status the part of us that gets
angry
they're supposed to be subordinate to
the rational part which which can
hopefully if it's developed properly
actually tell a person what would be
good for them or what would be bad for
them and this runs throughout ancient
philosophy you find this in Aristotle
just as much you find this and the
Stoics you find this in the Epicureans
you find this in tradition after
tradition after tradition all the way
down to the present you know day four
for Dostoevsky reformers including
utilitarians and socialists and all
sorts of other people reformers who want
to improve the society and improve human
beings so the dream is we could actually
have reason if it's properly developed
and if the appetites or desires however
you want to put them the effective part
of ourselves if it's properly
subordinated or integrated then we would
actually live a much better life any he
says you know if you think about this
what would this be like so he says let's
examine the possibilities what do you
say our wishes are mostly misguided
because of a mistaken evaluation of
what's in our interest if we sometimes
desire something that doesn't make sense
it's because in our stupidity we believe
that it's the easiest way to attain a
suppose that advantage so you know an
account that's been around for a very
long time why do people do dumb bad
shameful things well because they're
they're mistaken they they don't
understand what truly is in their
interest if they're rational capacities
were strengthened if they actually
followed reason well then they would
they wouldn't do that so he says
now what's gonna happen when desire
merges with reason then we will reason
instead of desiring it will be
impossible to retain reason and desire
something senseless that is harmful so
you know if I desire coffee after coffee
after coffee you know drinking three
four pots a day and my doctor points out
to me listen you really need to cut back
on the caffeine consumption and I'm like
well okay I'll drink decaf coffee four
pots a day and then the doctors like
well you know there's more to it than
that the acids are not good for your
stomach then I go through this entire
process I okay I'll replace it with them
something else I'm gonna drink tons and
tons and tons of tea and the doctor
might eventually get to the point where
he's like do you think that maybe that
excessiveness of needing to drink for
pot so something could be the problem oh
yeah you're right Eureka I have a
breakthrough now I don't desire that
anymore
right that's the way it should work you
have this great realization and you're
like oh that's bad for me I'm not gonna
do that anymore I thought it was good
for me I was mistaken
and so Dostoevsky says that's the way
that they they portray things he says
once are all of our desires and our
reasoning can be computed then we may
really have some sort of tables to guide
our desires like every everything else
and if you you know want a good example
of this dig around in Jeremy Bentham's
works don't just read the introduction
to the the the principles of morals and
legislation read some of his other stuff
look at the charts that he makes and
you'll see this sort of in action and
Dostoevsky says well that's that's fine
you can have that sort of project but
here's some considerations that you want
to keep in mind the first one is he says
reason can be satisfied and reason can
also be very satisfying in fact we often
find that there's something attractive
this is why Plato could catch on in the
first place or Aristotle or any of the
other philosophers
or even the religious thinkers who say
God gave us a Faculty of reason he wants
us to use it to the fullest
there is something attractive about
reason but reason is in some respect a
seducer it promises more than it can
give Dostoevsky says reason satisfies
only the human beings rational
requirements it does not satisfy all of
our other requirements and he guesses or
specifies just how much reason would
actually apply - he says oh maybe one
twentieth of our lives one twentieth of
the whole he says I instinctively want
to live to exercise all the aspects of
life and me not only reason which
amounts to perhaps one twentieth of the
whole maybe in some people it's 1/100
maybe in some people it's 1/5 maybe in
some people it's even one you know half
or let's say it's 99% if there's
something that is left out the person is
not going to be completely satisfied and
the problem is that reason can't
recognize and can't acknowledge that
it's not being completely satisfying
so he says reason is only reason it's
only satisfies our rational requirements
desire on the other hand is the
manifestation of life itself of all of
life and it encompasses everything from
reason down to scratching oneself so
desire is in in some respect more
encompassing and reason is just a part
of it or reason is just within you know
desires per view rather than desire
being within reasons you could think of
reason as a way in which perhaps he's
not saying this here but we could we
could extrapolate this as a way in which
desire works upon itself that would make
perfect sense
so desires of a much wider extent it
includes scratching yourself it includes
what you want to eat
includes all the things that you know
don't seem to be quite so amenable to
reason which would probably include also
our moral life our beliefs about what
you know is ultimate romantic
entanglements enemies friends pick
whatever it is that you like all the way
down to what sort of candy or beer or
coffee you prefer much of these things
have an immediate relationship with
desire that is lacking when we think
about reason so he goes on and he says
what does reason know it knows only what
it has had time to learn this is another
fundamental distinction between reason
and desire reason is really powerful but
it can't take into account what it
doesn't know adequately it's blind in
that respect it's blind to what it's
blind about somebody you know came up
and I'm sure it's not Rumsfeld
originally coming up with this the
distinction between known unknowns and
unknown unknowns Rumsfeld got a lot of
heat for this but it's actually a really
brilliant distinction reason doesn't
know what it doesn't know though there's
lots of unknown unknowns and it's not as
if did not desire knows them right or
desire is a new way of knowing or
anything like that reason does have the
advantage when it comes to generating
knowledge but desire relates itself to
reality much more directly
he says human nature is just the
opposite it acts as an entity using
everything it has conscious and
unconscious even if it deceives us it
lives
I suspect ladies and gentlemen you're
looking at me with pity wondering how I
can fail to understand that enlightened
cultured man such as a man in the future
could not deliberately wish to harm
himself you know and he goes on and on
and he talks about how it is that the
ordinary
person will come back to this in a
moment but think about this the ordinary
person has to have some sort of
immediate relationship with the world
because otherwise they have to wait
around for a philosopher to explain it
to them we'd never have a human race
right so through our desires we do in
fact relate ourselves the things far
beyond the scope of our knowledge and
through that we actually sometimes get
to know them
this is not something radically new by
the way that Dostoevsky is saying just
to give you one example of somebody else
who thinks something sort of like that
although he'd reject some of the
underground man's premises think about
Thomas Aquinas right the intellect knows
reality in certain ways it knows it
under the aspect of the true but the
will knows reality in a certain respect
even more directly even though it
doesn't necessarily cog NIH's it and
does so through practicality right the
realm of practical reasoning in which
desires and pursuit are analogous to
affirmation all right and version and
going away are analogous but not exactly
the same as denial the will grasps the
good and grasps reality as such which
even actually opens up a realm for our
emotions to insert in a certain way be a
thing connector not a thing a mode
connecting us to life more directly
now of course Thomas is more of a
rationalist than this underground man
he's got a great deal of confidence in
reason but we can see that this is a
part of the philosophical tradition we
don't have to go to somebody like Hume
saying reason can only be the slave of
the passions to recognize that the realm
of desire may in fact be much wider than
the realm of rash
allottee according to the underground
man he brings up another really
important set of points as well and we
touched on this in talking about desire
being more encompassing than reason or
rationality desire always possesses a
certain priority not only a practical
one but we could say an ontological one
one of the very core of human being over
rationality he tells us that desire can
if it wishes agree with reason that's up
to desire we often think that that
reason in some way or we portray reason
as in some way being able to coerce and
impose itself upon desire a must desire
actually decides to go along with it you
know sort of like indulging ones you
know eccentric uncle and saying oh yeah
sure let's go take a walk with you let's
see where we're going rationality
if desire doesn't choose to do that then
reason can talk and blather all at once
but it's really just talking to itself
desire is already thinking of the stuff
that it wants and not paying any
attention to what reason was a great
emblem of this could be thinking about
the typical college classroom where we
know from you know psychological
experiments that many of the students
are not actually paying attention the
entire time though they an instructor
might believe that they they are and
it's up to the instructor to somehow
reach the students and sometimes the
students won't be reached there are some
days where nobody's paying any attention
whatsoever because their minds around
something else so if we if desire does
go along with reads and it does so
because it chooses to or desires to or
wishes to write what else well what's
the normal case for desire and and
reason he says in reality desire usually
stubbornly disagrees with reason the
underground man goes further than most
people will and actually against many of
them in saying
and let me tell you this too is useful
and praiseworthy typically in philosophy
we look at desire and reason and their
conflict as if you know if there is a
disagreement we should always be on the
side of reason desire needs to shape up
and and quit you know being so obstinate
about these sorts of things and if it
does then it's you know it's good and if
it doesn't then it's bad and Dostoevsky
is willing to say well no maybe
sometimes right is on the side of desire
and not rationality the last thing and
this leads us into other discussions is
that perhaps it can be a desire for us
that we get to desire that we get to
follow our desires even if they are
irrational as he says a little bit
earlier talking about the stone wall and
saying that it's sort of the
metaphysical equivalent of people saying
two plus two equals four he says yes I
totally recognize that the rational part
of me grasped that that doesn't mean
that I have to accept it
I accept of course that the wall is
there I don't accept that I have some
sort of role in creating it or that I'm
responsible for it or that I even have
to follow the rule that's involved in
the wall I can smash my head into it if
I wish to perhaps it is true that we
actually have a desire to be able to
desire and you might call this following
Harry Frankfurt a second-order desire if
you like Dostoevsky is talking about
this a long time before that well over a
hundred years and this would be a desire
to actually get to decide things for
ourselves so as you can see desire has a
great priority over rationality for the
underground man and arguably for
Dostoevsky himself and this is in
opposition to much of the long-standing
tradition of philosophy
you